Thomas dimitrov is a friend of the
program and continuing like the Masters
in Georgia a tradition unlike any other
which is calling into this show prior to
a combine against you the listeners and
viewers of the show up and running and
inside a draft room and what it looks
like right now how you been Thomas
bridge I am well thanks for having me
once again so what does your draft board
look like right now
walk me through it going into a combine
well you know it's really interesting
because we've had two sets of meetings
we had meetings in December general our
general stack meetings and then in
February we have some very very detailed
position stack meetings so we go you
know in depth with all our position by
position and and then we you know
obviously during that time Ritz we're
comparing to what may be out there in
free agency which is a big belief of
mine you definitely have to make sure
you're making the right value moves
right so I think bringing free agency
into the discussion is a very good time
during during this time before we do
come to the combine so artboard is
stacked I'd say probably half way we
have a lot of work to do but is there a
number one overall honor in Atlanta
Falcons draft board in a room somewhere
right now there somebody a name there is
but I I'm like pretty paranoid given
where I've come from and that was a
tongue-in-cheek
of course I'm no I'm pretty particular I
have we have a couple different boards
in in the room and we have a couple of
computerized boards so I keep them mixed
up a little bit so no one truly knows
but for myself and Dan at this point
okay so just two people kind of know
that sort of thing when when does he get
involved if at all
you know he'll he'll sit in set of draft
meetings with us you know as we start
you know ripping through March in April
and we definitely have a final draft
meeting with them of course and we have
good discussions with them he'll be at
the combine he always comes to the
combine every year for one or two days
it's I like it it's become an annual
deal and we kneel at the st. Elmo's I'm
advertising of course and yes Indiana I
will sit down with him we'll talk talk
football he loves it so it's good well I
mean you
I mean you're already gonna get a good
table there Thomas I mean you don't have
to just drop names here to get a better
table when Arthur black strolls in with
you and Dan Quinn I mean you know all I
need all I need more than anything is
your name when I get into the big city
of Los Angeles there help me out drop it
you can drop my name any time Thomas
Dimitrov Atlanta Falcons general manager
joining me here so does does Arthur
Blank sit in the meetings with you when
you're going 15 minutes at a time with
the prospects you know he does like I
said he's usually here for two days and
he'll he'll come in and sit in and sort
of analyze I mean he's a guy as you know
who's been very outspoken in his in his
business ventures you know at Home Depot
and have a really good feel for people
and and so it's always interesting to
hear is insight after you know one of
these guys you know gets off the hot
seat and walks out the door after waxing
poetic and Arthur will have some really
quick tidbits for us it's it's it's
really it's really interesting to hear
from from a guy like him who is
understands leadership and business
building so what does it so I'm a
prospect I walk into the Atlanta Falcons
interview room what what do I see and
what do I encounter you see first of all
which you see a very relaxed room we
we've I've been in different rooms over
the years of 20 this of 26 years I think
at the combine where we've had a really
stodgy rigid room which doesn't lend
itself to some really good cool
conversation I'm a big believer in that
making it as casual as possible like
what like a lava lamp you got one
incense I mean what do you mean by
casual Thomas go ahead don't start don't
start bringing in yeah a lava lamps and
other other instruments that we're
talking time no we we don't do that but
what I will say is we get rid of the
table situation it's not like everyone's
sitting around we're definitely more in
a relaxed casual sofa and chairs no love
seats by the way they're good and we
just we just have a good conversation
and when the player comes in and and you
know we have you know myself of course
Scott Pioli and then Steve Sabol our
College Director and a few other people
we have the position coach Andy
coordinator and of course Dan Quinn and
I are sitting you know right there and
we're anchored in on the questions that
we want to ask and it's just usually a
pretty good interactive
and it's funny I was talking to someone
the other day actually another general
manager and we said some guys come in
and you wish you had 30 minutes other
guys coming in two minutes but you are
ready to kick them out the door it's
just the way it's like oh my gosh it's
time to go but sounds like some dates I
used to be on back in the day to be very
honest with you because because it does
I've been through this process to just
feel like it is speed-dating in a way
and then obviously there's the the
on-field drills which one do you think
for any position and any any position
any on-field drill do you think shows
you the most as a tower valuator from
the combine Wow
short of the Rich Eisen run when you
just make yourself right into that we
talked about that after I you know what
I think it's funny because I've looked
at so many positions over the years of
course when we focused on on them we've
each each position grouping has a drill
that I really own it on and you know my
biggest thing is making sure that we
really you know we look at the
athleticism the movement to stop start
ability that's a big thing for me and
interestingly enough during those
receiver sessions when we moved up and
historical I think 21 spots if I'm not
mistaken which by the way thanks for
always supporting me oh yeah yeah when I
remember watching those drills and being
really hone in on what it was like to
see see the receivers you know put the
foot in the ground and change direction
and separate those were big things so as
you know I'm really keyed in on the
athleticism side of this game we've
talked about it before so whether it's a
defensive back planning and going
flipping his hips whether it's an
offensive lineman you know in the mirror
drills it all has to do with how people
move how they redirect and what their
body controllers those are use of drills
that really catch my attention and we're
any drills you'd say I just don't need
it let's let's get out of there if you
could wave a wand for the combine times
you know what I'm not a big fan of the
timed back peddle drill for the for the
secondaries DB's I don't know why but
yeah the TV's on well just like the the
gauntlet always confuses me because
the gauntlet it's your your you want to
see how a receiver catches not like
catches and drops the ball but you
that's the that's bad we don't want to
see that you already have a problem to
catch rule you're exactly when we get to
a spot where we're all sitting around
waiting to see someone take it in the
beak and laugh so it's kind of sad so
it's it's for entertainment purposes
only is what you're saying oh my god
yeah there are some elements of
entertainment but I mean you can
obviously some get see some guys snatch
the ball in that drill but right it has
to do with the different people I mean
look we have people throwing the ball
along the line who I like there are some
guys out there that are Scouts and have
them thrown a ball or threw back thirty
years ago and you know you you're all
over the board that the people that are
throwing so it makes for entertainment
yes a couple more minutes here with you
Thomas dimitrov Falcons general manager
and just staying a little bit on on that
Julio Jones trade that you referred to
moving up 21 spots just give people an
idea of how it all works when you see
somebody on film and then you seem at
the combine and then you get an
interview and then there's a pro day and
all of that business and another
interview when did you and the rest of
the crew there that did include less
need now the GM in Atlanta I mean in LA
when did you guys say that's it we're
making this move we're going to do it
and we want it because it's for Julio
well interesting because it was a
process as you just mentioned I mean
through you know watching him as of
course the year before he was an
underclassman I mean I guess you know as
we're watch him on video we go to games
we see in the game we see him we see him
at the combine running on a broken foot
right basically and doing what he did
still popped off of go for three I
believe and he was running routes all
the separation drills I was talking
about earlier I think when we left the
combine and then we were going to
interview him which was probably about
you know two now more like 3 plus weeks
before the draft and I had gotten on the
phone with some teams at the top end of
the draft and one in particular with Tom
Heckert at the Browns at the point and
we were ready to go we were convinced
after our interview and spending time
with him taking the whole picture into
account that we thought this guy
would be a stud for us for years to come
if we could ever pull it off now at that
time we weren't sure if we had a you
know snowball's chance of course but
even when we first met him when we first
got into the hotel in Alabama to
interview him he basically looked away
when he shook my hand he thought these
guys have no chance why am I even
wasting my time
hey Dion said he would walk out of her
interview rooms because they thought
that they had no shot at him and just
dragged because he thought there's no
way man you never know who's gonna trade
up to come get you
you just know I want a piece of his
businesses but he hasn't bought into
that yet so last one for you where does
the contract conversation with Matt Ryan
stand right now between you and his son
yeah you know what we are we are we're
talking and and of course it's it's not
hot and heated at all I mean it's it's
it's in a it's in a little bit of a slow
pace right now and you know we're not in
any major rush we feel confident that
this a is not a very complicated
situation albeit you know significant as
you can imagine but we feel like you
know Matt wants to be at our place and
we we want them to be here for years to
come and we all have really good working
relationships we do not only with with
Matt of course but you know Tom Connor
and we've done a number of deals with
them so we're confident that this will
be accomplished in the right way in the
relatively near future well I mean isn't
there some bit of a clock Thomas so
somebody who let's say has way fewer
playoff wins than Matt Ryan sets a
market at a newer level and I I'm being
big serious I mean isn't there that's
exactly right
I mean I think yes there is an element
of that but I think the reality also is
you know if if you know Matt and and his
representation want to you know wait and
see what plays out over the next few
weeks obviously we can't force that of
course so you know we're standing by and
they're standing by to make decisions
and again hopefully in the roads of the
near future and do general
managers send each other's text like did
you send something to John Lynch saying
what are you doing brother come on now
something like that like what come on
what or anything like that would be I
don't even know that seems like
collusion but I'm not even sure if it is
but I will say to your point yes there's
probably a lot of how to even say that
on I don't want to say the wrong word
but there's a lot of butt busting on the
whole thing or whatever I'm trying to
say right yes there there's always a
little bit of pivoting that's an
old-fashioned word isn't it it's
ignoring it's a great word table this
look as the Jew here in Los Angeles it's
a good use of kibbutzim good job I will
say there's always a little bit of
joking around about it because look you
know you know there's a guy who there's
a very adept quarterback out in San
Francisco who was how many games as he
played six games yep he hasn't lost any
of him seven he's playing seven let's
not share with him one and he's done a
heck of a job and and I think his
numbers were significant so you know
that's that's like that's an interesting
and and can complicate things of course
now that's me laughing Nate Thomas I'll
see you out there in Indy thanks for
doing this as always and when when
you're in st. elmo's drop the word cubed
sing with Arthur I think Alan laughs I
appreciate it take care about thank you
got it Thomas Dimitrov the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience